now 30 years after they debuted with the
single the drowners rock band suede are
chasing their fourth number one album
they were original members of The Brick
pot movement alongside Oasis blur and
Pulp but you probably knew that already
let's take a listen to their latest
track
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm very pleased to say frontman Brett
Anderson joins me now live from West
London very good morning to you really
nice to talk to you this morning so tell
us a little bit about this album I read
that you wanted to go back to basics for
it so what exactly does that mean
I think you if you stick around long
enough you kind of you get more and more
sophisticated and there's a point where
you just want to kind of
get back to the energy and the
excitement of what it's like when you're
first in a band and that's this record
really it's a kind of like we call it
our Punk record it's not a punk record
it's sort of adversion of punk it's kind
of got all the messy bits and all the
energy and the kind of and the kind of
lack of respects that don't get us I
suppose but it's a kind of like it's a
it's just a live raw sounding record
quite Primal in places you know and it's
just an attempt to kind of like make a a
great Rock record you know
but how do you go by that how do you
strip out sophistication I know that you
work with the same producer I think as
as you did on your first single but how
do you get that feeling of a new
beginning when you've been doing it for
years yeah that's hard actually I mean
you've got to really feel it you've got
to really I think playing live a lot
really helps you know we play live a lot
and it's it's a very sort of like
visceral Primal experience
um we did a few things we we played them
a couple of gigs under an assumed name
um the name crash kid to almost like
start again with you know the idea was
that we were going to go into
um into a little tiny venue and place of
people that didn't know we were playing
and stuff like that and you've got to
kind of like slightly engineer these
things but um yeah it's hard you've got
you've just got you've got to feel it
though I think you've got to feel it
you've got to if you're if you're
excited about your your music then it'll
come through
how did that go there did everyone just
go hang on that suede
well the cat got out of the bag um yeah
it was actually and we did it in the
Moss Club in in Hackney and um and and
the defense chair Manchester and they
were kind of mad little gigs because the
fans actually ended up finding it
finding out his ass and and turning up
um but the idea was to do it in front of
one man and his dog
I don't think that's ever going to
happen again to you let's face it and
you've talked about this being a loud
noisy nasty Rock record but you've said
it's got the lyrical vulnerability that
comes with being an older man yeah and
some people might be surprised that you
think of yourself as being more
vulnerable as you get older some people
say surely you just get more
self-assured more confident with
experience well I don't know about
everyone else I kind of know speed for
myself but I don't find I think there's
a there's a kind of there's a sort of
assumption that as people's lives get
more comfortable in one sense that they
get more comfortable as people and in
one sense you know I'm kind of 55 I had
a fam I have a family I love and I'm
relatively comfortable in that sense but
I think there's there's kind of creeping
anxiety that you only have as a
middle-aged person you know kind of like
worries about the fragility of family
worries about mortality these kind of
things
um and I sort of wanted to reflect that
so I wanted it to be a rock record but
not from the perspective of a 25 year
old man very much from the perspective
of a 55 year old man I thought that was
quite an interesting kind of
um sort of Duality you know it hasn't
got the arrogance of Youth there's a lot
of there's a lot of hesitation there's a
lot of there's a lot of vulnerability in
there you know
and what about vulnerability about your
music as well does it get more
nerve-wracking putting music out there
when so much of the industry is geared
towards younger people do you lose
confidence in that area at all
um well you no I mean we we've got quite
a a a lovely um sort of healthy fan base
that always look after us which is kind
of amazing
um yeah I mean you're always going to be
competing against people and we're not
in the mainstream anymore but that can
be a that can be a kind of freedom in a
way I think when we were in in the
mainstream you can end up becoming
self-parody because you're kind of
trying to chase a formula
um and being free of the mainstream
being away from the mainstream allows
you quite a lot of creative kind of I
don't know you can experiment a bit more
like the last album the album before
were very very experimental records
there's lots of kind of like sound
sounds and and and and field recordings
and kind of odd moments on those records
which I don't think we would have ever
done if we'd have released them in the
90s we've been had we wouldn't have that
artistic Freedom so you have to look at
every situation and assess it and sort
of look at the good things about it and
use those as opportunities I think and
you enjoying yourself are you pleased
with that have you been enjoying gigging
of course I mean I love it more and more
as I get older actually that's a strange
thing the older I get
um the more I love playing live is you
sort of you can use
um your experience if you if you can
stay relatively fit and stick around
long enough you can kind of use your
experience you know when you first Go on
stage is this sort of weird kind of
blurry experience and you don't know
what's going on and then I'm going to
cut in because we're just going
completely running out of time I've only
got a matter of seconds left and we keep
talking about your age but I should
point out I'm still a year older than
you so it's all good Brett Anderson
really good to talk to you thanks very
much for your time this morning thank
you